justement je crois qu'on peut en parler
on vous a vu très proche d'un certain
chat noir alors la question que tous vos
fans se posent auriez-vous une
confidence à nous faire à ce sujet et
oui oui
est-ce que tout va bien ladybug
mais on se retrouve au cinéma
le trajet pourrait se faire rapidement
mais la route est truffée de nid de
poule
attention voilà en gros
parfois ça va et parfois on a
l'impression d'être à cheval la
propulsion se fait de façon curieuse et
on pense en effet plutôt des gens qui
est d'obstacles qu'on gracieuse
parisienne qui osent encore descendre à
bicyclette les Champs-Élysées
1000 euros l'amende que SNCF voyageur a
été condamné à verser à deux plaignantes
la société a été reconnu coupable de
négligence dans l'affaire du chat écrasé
par un TGV en gare de Montparnasse le 2
janvier le chat Neco avait échappé en
s'en souvient la tension de ses
maîtresses qui s'apprêtaient à quitter
Paris pour Bordeaux et c'était réfugiés
sous le train malgré les demandes des
propriétaires de l'animal pour retarder
le départ et bien le train était parti
en écrasant le félin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'adore il y a rien de plus sexy qu'un
homme qui rougit
chocolat glace c'est que c'est
ah bon il se passe des choses derrière
vous pouvez voir je vais essayer de
rester concentré mais c'est pas sûr que
j'y arrive il y a un Thomas Sotto qui se
cache derrière ma chaise alors Thomas
Thomas qui fait des boules cachette
Thomas on vous voit même pas faire les
roulades on aimerait vous voir Thomas
voilà
[Rires]
en l'honneur de leur Dieu
ils vont devoir porter ce tronc d'arbre
de plusieurs tonnes
sur 5 km
sans jamais le laisser tomber ni même le
poser à terre
l'échec n'est pas possible il signerait
une année de malheur
[Applaudissements]
les gens vous trouvent ringarde bonjour
madame bonjour Bernadette se dévoile les
premières images du film sur l'ancienne
première dame sont sorties et elles ont
séduit de nombreux internautes Catherine
Deneuve de retour au cinéma pour jouer
en plus une Bernadette Chirac prête à
tout pour se faire aimer des Français
certains perdent encore y croire ce
serait même le film le plus improbable
de l'année moi j'aurais peut-être dit
Carla Bruni parce qu'elle avait une sa
guitare pour un gros micro parce que la
peau de voit donc
[Rires]
c'est sympa nous on a on l'adorait
jusqu'à maintenant la vie est une
machine à jouir
une machine à jouir
apparemment Fabien il en a
ce candidat doit rester quelques mois
il m'efforce empathique
duo enflammé entre Travis Scott et
Gabriel nantait de 18 ans ce week-end
lors d'un festival à la Rotterdam la
suite nous est racontée par ce jeune fan
du rappeur mais là mais comme des dingue
tous les deux il enlève son t-shirt d'un
coup je l'ai récupéré le tir de triste
c'est une grille et je suis un rappeur
avec lui mais je récupère son t-shirt
qui commence à enlever ses chaussures
mais là mon cerveau il explose
j'habite seul avec maman
c'est un bon 44 et demi une paire qui
vaut cher Gabriel a déjà refusé des
offres allant jusqu'à 50000 euros
regarde cette petite place sur laquelle
on va aller on va monter sur le trottoir
et après tu vas pouvoir rouler toute
seule hop là mais tu l'as vu
en fait il y a des boutons d'appel
au-dessus des du panneau dans l'avion au
dessus sur le plafond donc
excusez-moi en fait les moteurs font
trop de buts trop de bruit est-ce qu'on
pourrait les éteindre pour que je puisse
dormir et en fait au début qui doute de
rien et il est dans la vanne où il est
très sérieux et très énervé c'est un
clip censé promouvoir le tourisme aux
Philippines une vidéo partagée par les
autorités mais certaines images viennent
d'ailleurs exemple cette rizière est en
fait en Indonésie c'est d'une se situe
aux Émirats arabes unis et si vous
atterrissez sur cette piste vous êtes
azurique en Suisse c'est un blogueur
philippin qui a tout dévoilépreuve à
l'appui la vidéo a été retirée l'agence
qu'il a réalisé s'est excusée lancement
raté donc pour la nouvelle campagne
nommée j'aime les Philippines qui a tout
de même coûté 900 000 euros au
gouvernement
ah je roule ah je roule des patins aux
deux je suis une catin 30 ça va très
bien je suis ravi pour vous Madame